when I'm teaching on generosity I often
quote Margaret Thatcher who said no one
would remember that Good Samaritan if he
only had good intentions he had money as
well and if you remember the story of
the Good Samaritan
the Pharisees walked past a wounded man
and the Good Samaritan comes along picks
up the wounded man takes him back to the
inn and has to the innkeeper to care for
him care for his wounds feed him house
him and leaves him money to do so and
says when I come back through if there
is need of more money I will leave more
money it takes money - sometimes it
takes money to cause things to move
forward if you want to be generous you
can have good intentions and say oh I
really wish I could help that that's a
good cause I wish I could but if you put
yourself in a position to be generous
financially you've lived like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else
then when a need comes across your path
something that you're passionate about
particularly you can do something about
it and you can write a check and
sometimes you can do it with great Flair
and great style like happened yesterday
if you didn't hear there was a horrible
fire in Paris and the Cathedral of Notre
Dom which I was able to visit a couple
years ago portions of it burned and
everyone was holding their breath that
they could get the fire put it out
before it was a total loss obviously
they lost the spire and some other
things but it's not only a it's been
there since what eleven hundred and
sixty-three I think it was built
something like that and so it is not
only a Christian chapel a Catholic
chapel but it is also an icon on the
world stage and certainly on the stage
of Paris and so everyone was kind of
holding their breath watching this -
French families have already come out
and pledged three hundred and thirty
nine million dollars between the two of
them
to help with the rebuilding and
wonderful I'll just read from Washington
Post here or Washington Times rather one
of the france's richest families
promptly stepped up to calls from the
country's president to help rebuild the
cathedral pledged 113 million shortly
thereafter another wealthy family
offered another 226 million of the
restoration fund and one of the families
is the lv h m company which i think is
the largest company in france if i
recall it and lv h m is louis vuiton lv
and that's where the initial money was
made with the company they still own
that brand they also home a bazillion
other brands in a seat cognac as an
example several other brands that are
uniquely French and some around the
world it's a huge company but the family
made their wealth in business and then
are you know that went pledging 226
million dollars back into this the irony
is the French generally like socialism
but capitalism is what's writing this
check because these are companies that
made money selling well the initial
money was made selling extremely
expensive purses hello and evel rich
people bought those purses of course so
it could have happened in the Ramsey
family I'm just saying but we might have
funded part of that indirectly I'm just
saying but it's a big deal
it's and and I think it's interesting to
stop and say you know the French
president called on people to help
rebuild to help with this restoration
immediately to wealthy families the evil
one percenters right then there are
these poor evil rich people are the
first ones to write checks and it's
hundreds of millions of dollars so
obviously they're not evil and obviously
they're generous and obviously they care
not only about the faith aspect of this
I suspect I don't know that for sure but
they definitely care about France and
they care about Paris and they care
about the this icon on the world stage
and
congratulations for your generosity and
putting it out there to inspire the rest
of us most of us can't ride 100 million
or two in a million dollar check but it
reminds us all to write the hundred
dollar check or hand somebody a couple
of Benjamin Franklin's that's down on
their luck and help them and you can't
do that if you're trying to pay your
light bill because you're out of control
so you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else now you will be criticized there's
only one way to avoid criticism do
nothing say nothing and be nothing and
so you can count on being criticized as
you become successful as you build
wealth but then you're in a position to
do wonderful things like that and I
suspect some of france's wealthiest
families don't really care what you
think they don't really care how what
you think about how they made their
money they're probably not concerned
about your opinion they didn't write
this check for that they weren't
motivated by popularity this is not a
reality show this is life and that's
what happens when you the larger you get
in business the larger you get on the
stage of life the more some pissant will
take a potshot at you and that happens
all the time it's just part of it and
you just you just go well as if I was
taking a poll I'm not taking a poll
we're doing this as for me and my house
we're gonna serve the Lord that's
something you're offended when I say
that on radio turn the channel this is
the Dave Ramsey show and I'll be
continuing to say what I want to say and
if you wanted to hear what somebody else
said you should have listened to a
different show and if your opinion
matters get you a show that's how this
works and so my encouragement is to be
successful go be what God called you to
be go live on less than you make so that
later you can live and give
like no one else pay a price to win and
then ignore the haters when you win and
move on because they will be there some
of them will be jealousy from the old
neighborhood some of them will be Envy
from inside your own family some of them
will be left wingers who are mad about
everything some of them will be
something right they all come from
somewhere and everybody's got an opinion
about you the more you have succeeded so
congratulations to these wonderful
wealthy families and friends thank you
for doing something wonderful with your
wealth and and really encouraging the
rest of us in our generosity journey to
be outrageously generous see I got this
weird idea that if enough of you got out
of debt and enough of you built wealth
you and I we the people could out give
the government and make them irrelevant
how fun would that be